what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so it's been a little while since
we've done a character explanation we
did the vulture but the vulture was
really more of like can I still do these
and I think we can I think I'm still the
comic-book explanation guy on YouTube or
at least a character explanation guy on
YouTube that's a to my own horn but I
feel like my character explanation
videos were pretty darn good you know
back when I was doing them consistently
and getting back into original content I
want to come jump back into that again
but in this video we're going to be
talking about the Incredible Hulk now
some of you guys might be scratching
your head considering all the hope
videos that I've done you're just kind
of like you've never done an Incredible
Hulk explained I did back when I first
started but the issue was that I was
still flushing out character
explanations because of that video was
something like eight minutes long or
something along those lines
it wasn't here you know wasn't really on
par with my traditional character
explanation videos and so in this one
we're Lee going to kind of beef that up
one of the other things that I want to
talk about here is what's going on with
Marvel legacy now those are the guys who
have looked up the different
solicitations which is to say Marvel
basically teasing what comics are coming
out with Marvel legacy you'll notice the
Incredible Hulk is basically kicking off
with issue number 709 now the reason why
Mobile's doing that is because of the
fact that while the Incredible Hulk
title the name has changed over the
years has been indestructible Hulk
simply just called Hulk it's been be
Incredible Hulk and the fact remains
that over the course of Marvel's entire
publication history regardless of what
the title was called there have been 708
comics that have been dedicated to a
solo series for the Incredible Hulk
and so what Marvel is doing is basically
coming back and saying this is basically
the 709th comic of the Incredible Hulk
that has in some form or fashion
been a solo series and so the Incredible
Hulk first appeared in Marvel Comics in
May of 1962 with Incredible Hulk issue
number one and he was created by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby and that was par for
the course back then remember back in
the 1960s a Marvel was really first
beginning to gain steam it was really
just an attempt to crank out as many
characters as humanly possible I mean
the introduction of Barry Allen in DC
Comics had basically set in motion the
Silver Age so to speak or the second
Renaissance of comic books and so now
come over characters were just as
popular as they had ever been but the
Incredible Hulk was not just an
arbitrary creation by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby instead he really had his roots in
Ben Grimm the thing from the Fantastic
Four and the reason for that was because
of the fact that the Fantastic Four were
the first family of Marvel if Marvel
wanted to
introduced a character or team in the
Marvel Universe or bolster in existing
character or team's popularity they
featured them in the Fantastic Four will
actually find out they did that with you
Incredible Hulk here in a little bit but
initially the Incredible Hulk was just
designed to be Stan Lee's attempt to
kind of take this Frankenstein slash dr.
Jekyll mr. Hyde dichotomy and then merge
it into a singular beam but the whole
the whole basis behind this was that
with Ben Grimm it was established that
there was a measure of popularity when
it came to just really strong powerhouse
characters I mean Thor was the exact
same way when he came later on down the
line it was basically the idea that some
fans just want to see a character just
wreck stuff but Stan Lee was not without
some kind of poetry when it came to the
different characters that he made and so
again kind of reminiscing in this whole
dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde thing the Incredible
Hulk was designed to be the sort of
epitome of human nature whereas Bruce
Banner was the epitome of just like
rational thought rational thinking now
what the to represent have just kind of
changed waxed and waned over the years
and the metaphors are evenly exchanged
but the fact remains it's basically this
idea that the Incredible Hulk represents
the darker side of things it's unbridled
rage unbridled hatred so on and so forth
and the cool thing is that they'll
actually be a guy named bill Mantlo here
in a little while that will talk about
who will sort of move this into a whole
new echelon but Stan Lee's idea with
regards to the Incredible Hulk was to
originally make him gray and that's why
if you look at the original Incredible
Hulk 1 through 6 series he is a great
character and the goal of San Lee was to
basically move away from anything that
had to do with any sort of cultural
appropriation which is to say he didn't
want the Incredible Hulk to basically be
a representation of any one particular
race now back then it was really just
the idea of you know playing it pretty
even keel playing pretty a pretty
reasonable with a character's
development in this day and age it would
really be more people looking at that
and saying well yeah I mean he doesn't
want to upset anybody or something along
those lines but regardless of the
motivation behind it The Incredible Hulk
actually was not very popular when he
first showed up and the reason for that
was because of the fact that much like
you know the x-men when they first crept
up on the scene Marvel already had Ben
Grimm they already had the thing and he
was on a team with the Fantastic Four it
why were you so worried about the
Incredible Hulk
when you could read a story about the
thing and so the result was that after
about six issues or so Marvel basically
cancelled the Incredible Hulk story but
the goal was that Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby kind of looked at what was
happening and said well maybe we just
kind of like left before we look maybe
we just kind of jump too far too fast
and so the idea was to basically wrap
the incredib
back in to the Fantastic Four and
various other anthology series before
they actually went through and started
jumping in and giving him his own solo
story and so what had happened was that
in March of 1963 with the cancellation
of a series in issue number six in turn
Steve Ditko a handful of others really
just sort of looked at the id8
Incredible Hulk and rolled him over into
the Fantastic Four issue number 12 and
so what ended up happening is following
this in the advent of the Avengers B
Incredible Hulk was rolled over as the
antagonist of the Avengers themselves
and that's really one of the interesting
things about the story is because one of
the biggest misconceptions people have
is that like Captain America for example
started the Avengers it was actually
Hank Pym and Janet Van Dyne who brought
the Avengers together originally it was
simply the idea that Loki it popped up
on the scene and Loki had decided to use
the Hulk to his own ends in order to
instigate a conflict it ended up seeing
the you know the unification of really
the most powerful non mutant superheroes
at the time which resulted in the
formation of the Avengers team and so
following this the actual concept of
Bruce Banner you know being given his
name Robert Bruce Banner came in amazing
spider-man nation number 14 in 1964 and
for the most part that was really what
his stories were his story was you know
it was really just kind of him being
rolled over at the tales of astonish in
anthology series you know that really
just kind of picked up with him being
rolled in in issue number 60 and it was
just really just you know the Incredible
Hulk alongside several other characters
that were being featured at the time and
it actually turned out to be a pretty
genius move by Marvel just because of
the fact that instead of forcing people
to go out and buy a singular comic about
a character they weren't really
interested in instead they got to buy a
comic to figure a whole bunch of
characters and so if they were
interested in the Incredible Hulk right
ends and so on and so forth that would
really just kind of no beef up they
character a little bit more it would
give Marvel an indication of what it was
that people were wildly interested in or
what they thought to be pretty
intriguing and so the result was that
over the course of his publication
history eventually the tales to astonish
line was effectively dropped off at
issue number 101 and it began The
Incredible Hulk vol 2 with issue number
102 and the reason why this is so
important is because of the fact that
this actually was really written by Lynn
wine between 1974 and 1978 and this
coincides almost directly with the
introduction of Wolverine and in fact
we'll probably have a discussion about
him at a later point in time but the
long and short of his character was that
Len Wein alongside herb shrimp who was
drawing it at the time
or basically tasked with the idea of
just creating a character named will
very
who is going to be the sort of not
necessarily as strong and as powerful as
The Incredible Hulk was but every bit is
Savage and so of course Wolverine proves
to be relatively popular was eventually
rolled over into giant-size x-men issue
number one the following year and then
became part of the main x-men roster
under Chris Claremont but again this is
really kind of how Marvel did things
back in the 1960s 1970s and even go into
the 80s and early 90s it was the idea of
just having this giant melting pot of
characters crossing over characters
being introduced and other characters
books and then ultimately hoping those
characters would succeed which some of
them did and some of them didn't but
about your mains here with one line
being a pretty celebrated writer with a
varsity Incredible Hulk and even getting
his own television series later on in
issue number 245 in March of 1980 a guy
by the name of bill Mantlo came onto the
scene now bill Mantlo at the time was
really more of like a fledging writer
when it came to Marvel Comics he was
basically just a guy that was a fill-in
writer and the reason for that was
because of the fact that the editor in
chief of Marvel at the time and I want
to say it was Len Wein but I don't think
it was but the editor in chief at the
time basically had this idea that Marvel
was running into issues of you know
prints being delayed different things
like that because they were all
hand-drawn Marvel wanted to make sure
that there were always filling stories
whenever you know a particular story was
running late so if it was be Incredible
Hulk and it was a six issue limited
series or a six issue run and issue
number six was running late mother
wanted to make sure that they had a
fill-in story between five and six and
so what they did is they basically cast
bill Mantlo with creating all these
different filling stories and he
actually did a pretty good job with
regards to the entire gamut of Marvel
superhero lineup and the result was that
with issue number 245 he was rolled over
now for bill Mantlo looking at the
Incredible Hulk one of the biggest
issues that he saw was that going into
the 80s and looking at the environment
of covering books at the time he got to
remember in 1971 when Stacy died and so
it made comics a little more visceral
and introduced the notion that a
superhero could fail and so what it
meant is that even he could in turn make
the Incredible Hulk more human he can
make him a little more relatable make
him a little more tangible and so the
idea was to introduce the notion of
Bruce Banner having been a product of
child abuse and so what bill Mantlo did
is he introduced the story of Bruce
banners father being an extremely
abusive man in relation to both Bruce's
mother as well as as Bruce himself and a
lot of this was rooted in the fact that
Bruce was so smart as a child
as of this The Incredible Hulk was
basically twisted into this notion of
kind of representing all the suppressed
rage and all the suppressed anger that
Bruce Banner had kept inside after you
know dealing going to all these ordeals
with his father abusing him you know
beating him up and different things like
that and so again it turned out to be
wildly popular with regards to the
incredible whole mythos just because of
the fact that people love to see
failings in the character they love to
know that the Incredible Hulk was just a
guy who is really just sort of
struggling you know for the most part
now of course up to this point over the
course of marvel's publication history
different people have been introduced
tales to astonish saw the introduction
of the leader you know characters like
Betty Ross the love interest of Bruce
Banner where we're introducing different
things along those lines but the idea
was that looking at the Incredible Hulk
landscape and looking at all these
different things that had taken place
with bill Mantlo effectively ending his
run John Byrne and a handful of others
taking over leading to Peter David
taking over the story with issue number
331 the goal was to basically remove
Betty Ross from the equation and the
reason why is because of the fact that
for a lot of people really a lot of
higher-ups and Marvel they look at Betty
Ross is the kind of Mary Jane Watson of
the Incredible Hulk mythos and what I
mean by that is in the spider-man comics
Mary Jane Watson put an age on Peter
Parker it takes him away from the
relatable nature that made him so
popular initially in the sense that she
majors looked at him and saw a
reflection of themselves and so the
result was that of course you know as
most people know in one more day Peter
Parker spider-man
it's where the mayor's to Mary Jane
Watson was nullified this whole thing
with regards to Betty Ross back in 1998
was effectively the exact same maneuver
just by a different means and so by
removing Betty Ross in the equation the
goal was to take away the one thing that
allowed the Incredible Hulk to be calm
that allowed the Incredible Hulk to
relax that could have potentially been
the way by which a future writer could
remove the entire Incredible Hulk
landscape I need to turn the character
into something totally unrelated or turn
him into something better the problem is
that was a coin flip and Marvel didn't
want to take the risk and so the result
was that where Betty Ross was
essentially killed off
Marvel wanted to bring the whole idea of
you know savage Hulk back into the
equation to make the Incredible Hulk
just as cruel and brutal as he was
before now of course during this whole
era where Peter David had taken over the
title the overall jess was that he had
written a litany of stories that helped
to expand on the Incredible Hulk in a
way that was never thought possible a
lot of these were really just kind of
focused on the notion of the
relationship between Bruce Banner and
Hulk himself a lot of them really
revisited the bill Mantlo stories of the
incredible hope suffering different
forms of child abuse but one of the most
notable aspects is what the world would
look like if the Incredible Hulk became
a bad guy and this actually came out of
a two-part original graphic novel called
future imperfect the future imperfect
introduced a villain by the name of
maestro Hulk which was basically a
version of The Incredible Hulk
in the dystopian future who was
irradiated with nuclear energy and was
essentially just the last remaining
superhero on earth or at least the last
remaining super-powered being on earth
and ultimately was ruling this city
called dystopia but the maestro Hulk of
course word saw the traditional
Incredible Hulk you know more or less
brought over through the timestream to
fight maestro maestro was faster he was
stronger he was smarter he was basically
a cut above the Incredible Hulk as we
knew him and where it did introduce some
pretty incredible stories it also
introduced the idea of the Incredible
Hulk having a fear of what he would
become later on down the line if he
wasn't kept in check at the same time it
also saw events like the onslaught saga
for example you know Marv we're kind of
looking around at their landscape then
realizing that if it wasn't called x-men
and wasn't called spider-man then it
simply wasn't selling they basically
wanted to kind of do the soft reboot
with the Avengers Fantastic Four and so
on and so forth and so they essentially
had this onslaught entity this
amalgamation of Charles Xavier mind and
powers and Magneto's mind and powers
kind of merging together leading to
onslaught basically just running amuck
through the entirety of the planet Earth
the Bruce Banner personality was
essentially suppressed by Jean Grey
which eventually led to you know this
sort of return of the savage Hulk simply
by a different means and the result was
that it was popular for a time but the
overarching goal was to kind of you know
return things to a measure of
familiarity the problem with this is
that when Peter David left the
Incredible Hulk title all the work that
he had done effectively went down the
drain
and the reason why was because nobody
was able to continue the various stories
that he had pulled off to write things
the way that he did and so the result
was that over the course of the next you
know six or seven years going into 2004
2005 2006 The Incredible Hulk just kind
of wandered around the Marvel landscape
he'd pop up the stories here and there
and things would happen but he was
really much a return to 1960s 1970s Hulk
where nothing of significance ever
really happened in his stories now this
began to change when it came to the
House of M with regards to Peter David
kind of coming back on temporarily and
writing a few of the Incredible Hulk
stories but ultimately bailed out just
because of the fact that he didn't want
to be the incredible
guy and so what this did is it set two
stage for the introduction of Greg pack
to take over the title now Greg pack
largely looked at the writings of Peter
David look to the writings of bill
Mantlo and even John Byrne and a handful
of others and used all those four
individual stories you know to craft on
his own and the result was that Greg
pack immediately set about basically
instigating a series of events whereby
The Incredible Hulk
would basically be the front runner and
Bruce Banner would be to be the
background character and the reason for
this was because of the fact that for
the most part when it came to the
Incredible Hulk stories historically
speaking even under man Lowe's run even
under Peter David run it was always
about looking at the Incredible Hulk and
Bruce Banner together never really just
one or the other and so the result is
that Greg Pak decided to instigate an
event called Planet Hulk which would see
you know the Incredible Hulk basically
removed for the planet Earth mmm through
incidental means crash landing on the
planet calls to car and what this did is
it basically rusty Incredible Hulk into
the front landscape with hide nor hair
of Bruce Banner he was effectively gone
it was strictly an Incredible Hulk story
and what this did is it set in motion
this multi-year epic the del would be
Incredible Hulk coming back to earth
after you know he had found love on the
car only to how to take in length really
just kind of waging a war against the
superhero community just crushing
everybody it was a story that was
designed to look at the very nature of
the Incredible Hulk and say what happens
when the very dark nature of humanity
this kind of savage aspect of what makes
people who they are really become
sentient and then decides to turn its
guns against humanity and that's what
the Incredible Hulk did he actually just
ripped everything apart now again we
have all these videos down in the
description so you don't really have to
worry about that too much I mean you're
welcome to go and check all those out so
we're not going to go through every
single iota of those but the idea here
was that in the middle of Greg pack
basically writing his whole run we also
saw the introduction of Red Hulk we also
saw characters like Rick Jones becoming
a bomb you know of course we saw the
return of characters like abomination
and different things like that a lot of
these individuals who have been villains
or they were allies whatever the case
may be being rolled over into the
Incredible Hulk mythos in a wholesale
revamp of the landscape again the
biggest issue with this is that once
Greg pack left the Incredible Hulk just
kind of found himself tumbling down the
rabbit hole of these small-time stories
that didn't last anything more than you
know 10 20 issues until they were
cancelled and then just kind of you know
being relaunched with a different name
and a few more stories being told and
the whole thing
being canceled and so on and so forth
and so really you know with guys like
Jason Aaron picking up the pen and
working on Incredible Hulk stories
proper not a whole lot was done with
regards to expansion on the Incredible
Hulk mythos instead it was really more
of just writing stories that weren't
interesting that were intriguing what if
Bruce Banner and The Incredible Hulk had
two separate bodies different things
like that and so ultimately because of
the fact that Greg Pak had introduced a
character named Amadeus Cho a
korean-american who's one of the
smartest people on the planet who for
the most part was really just kind of a
supporting character throughout the
entire run of Incredible Hulk what he
ended up doing with all-new
all-different marvel was basically
removing Bruce Banner from the equation
and putting Amadeus Cho Hulk in its
place now this has received a lot of
mixed reviews and the reason was because
a lot of people who have been reading
The Incredible Hulk only ever read about
Bruce Banner he was really the only hope
he ever got it always consolidated back
down to Bruce Banner himself and so the
result was that people looked at the
entire set of events and said ultimately
it's not the character that they're used
to it's not the character that they want
this was compounded by the fact that
we're fans hoped that Bruce Banner would
return and there were even some teases
to the idea that Bruce Banner might come
back this all effectively went away when
Bruce Banner was shot and killed by
Hawkeye during the events of civil war -
as divisive as that story was it
ultimately led to this idea that Bruce
Banner was never going to come back and
so because of the fact that mob would
receive so much backlash from regards
you know to the death of Bruce Banner -
the idea that the Incredible Hulk as we
knew him would return it basically set
in motion the whole Marvel legacy event
or at least one of the things that set
in motion the whole Marvel legacy of
them which eventually led to the
incredible whole kind of being rolled
back in again and the idea of Bruce
Banner retaking his mantle for the very
least you know we emerging back there's
another version of The Incredible Hulk
but so that being said guys I mean we've
covered enough Hulk stuff and I think
it's popular enough that when it comes
to his powers they're pretty
straightforward I mean this strength is
limitless and it's infinite you know so
long as he's alive long enough to keep
getting angrier he'll keep getting
stronger now I mean there are beings out
there that can destroy the Incredible
Hulk Incredible Hulk stability is
strength and durability and it's really
durability against some pretty powerful
beings of course against conventional
weapons but somebody who can work
reality cosmic entities Galactus them
and things like that
The Incredible Hulk in he really can't
take those guys out I mean I can't
really envision a scenario where the
incredible art would be so strong he
would be able to take out Galactus I've
never really heard of anything like that
happened
and even in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which kind of pushed things to
the extreme the Incredible Hulk
would really be no match for Loki I mean
it's really just not one of those things
that works when it comes to pure
strength sure when it's just a you know
a fist to fist brawl knock-down drag-out
fight yes the Incredible Hulk will take
the cake but giving all the the
knowledge that Loki has on sorcery and
magic and so on and so forth there's a
million things you could do to to take
out the Incredible Hulk um it was a cool
moment just incredible just smashing him
around like a rag doll but at the end of
the day The Incredible Hulk stability is
strength and so of course it's limitless
but it's confined to him just basically
kind of having to punch people
you know if he's facing a foe that you
can't touch then the Incredible Hulk is
about as useless as anybody else so with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to comments explained
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like I leave a comment down below let me
know what are the characters that are
coming out as part of Marvel legacy or
characters that are in DC rebirth or you
want to see me do discussions on and I
will catch you all later
Oh